[Música]
para flores
buenas tardes a todos voy a hablar desde
el calentamiento que está muy bien en un
día tan fresquito como hoy les habrá
extrañado que haga frío estamos en
noviembre y ya nos hemos acostumbrado a
que bueno que no haga tanto frío les voy
a hablar un poco del calentamiento en
breves palabras para contarles lo que
hemos hecho algunos miles de científicos
en el mundo que es hacer una memoria de
800 páginas sobre el cambio global el
calentamiento global y tengo 9 minutos
así que como comprenderán no me he leído
las 800 páginas y voy a hacer un resumen
bastante breve como hoy es viernes
probablemente más de uno habrá dicho
cómo va a ser el fin de semana bueno ya
lo han visto fresquito mañana y una
tregua el domingo viene más pero
realmente los modelos metodológicos pues
se comportan bastante bien tenemos
bastante bastante confianza más que en
otras cosas
hace años esto empezó empezó con una
pizarra un señor que salía en televisión
mariana medina ahora realmente todos
sabemos porque tenemos muchas
muchas herramientas en el móvil en la
televisión en cualquier sitio y
realmente hemos llegado a tener una
buena bueno realmente confiamos bastante
bien en ello
cómo va a ser la semana que viene
bueno ya no me pidas tanta exactitud ya
vamos a ver si el domingo entra a un
frente que parece que entra con no muy
buena pinta pues probablemente al
principio de semana pues ahora bueno
pero ya empezamos a alargar un poco es
decir empezamos a buscar un poquito
menos menos de exactitud
aún así más o menos nos podemos aclarar
es decir pasando el tiempo vamos
perdiendo la exactitud de los modelos
porque realmente eso es lo que lo que
ocurre y nosotros queremos mucha
precisión un territorio muy determinado
algo muy muy concreto
si nos dicen cómo va a hacer este
invierno
bueno pues ahora frío pero no siempre a
la frío y cuánto va a llover en
primavera
no sé
ya los modelos aquí no nos llegan porque
les estamos pidiendo en león lo que va a
ocurrir en primavera y en una época muy
determinada
esto ya empieza a complicarse porque
nosotros lo que queremos es concretar
esto es como cuando te dicen por la
mañana qué tal va a hacer hoy y les dice
es una temperatura y te dicen pero que
me pongo ya tanto tanto tanto ya ya no
llega quiere decir que esto es de
brujerías esto de saber exactamente todo
lo más que te pueden decir y con una
cierta aproximación es si va a haber más
o menos que lo que es habitual o si va a
hacer más o menos frío
ya empezamos a entrar en otro en otro en
otro mundo y es hombre
el calendario zaragozano y ya está
pero si queremos tenemos una boda o un
evento o cualquier cosa y queremos que
con meses de antelación queramos saber
qué es lo que va a ocurrir un día y
además no es que lo queramos saber
cuidado es que nos interesa que haga
bueno
que es distinto eso ya más de uno dirá
yo ya sé lo que tengo que hacer
verdad
llevar los huevos a las clarisas eso es
un asunto de huevos que hay que llevarlo
y hay que ponerlo como tiene que ser
ellas van a rezar y van a pedir no
solamente porque haga bueno por si acaso
sino porque el matrimonio que se va a
llevar a cabo pues sea feliz y duradero
el caso es que en esta en estos asuntos
lo que estamos viendo es que algo está
pasando en el otoño se alarga vemos
muchas noticias en la prensa nacional de
la prensa internacional esto lo vemos
y tenemos muchísima información y
tenemos en nuestra retina imágenes de
grandes tormentas de grandes sequías por
otro lado de avenidas
es decir un poco de drama al fin y al
cabo dramas hay una cosa que está
clarísima y es que está fuera de toda
duda que la tierra se está calentando no
hay ninguna duda el 98% del territorio
está comprobado que en el último siglo
ha aumentado la temperatura y no hay
ninguna duda
y al mar lo ha hecho muy deprisa esto se
nota en muchísimas cosas la temperatura
el deshielo la subida del mar hay más
fenómenos extremos en fin una serie de
cosas es no hay ninguna duda en este
momento ya nadie nadie lo dudamos
la pregunta es por qué el por qué es
tiene su razón probablemente muchos de
ustedes hayan oído hablar de qué
bueno hay un efecto de calentamiento y
del efecto invernadero que es el efecto
invernadero bueno pues todo sabemos lo
que es un invernadero es un sitio que
tiene en el techo una serie de cristales
entra el sol
efectivamente entra hasta abajo calienta
el suelo ese calor intenta salir hacia
el exterior sale un poquito pero no todo
y por tanto en esa zona se va acumulando
y acumulando el calor que es lo que pasa
que al final tenemos ahí una zona más
calentita que es lo que estamos haciendo
nosotros nosotros lo que estamos
haciendo es este efecto invernadero se
da siempre pero lo que estamos haciendo
nosotros es aumentar y aumentar el
número de cristales es decir el
aislamiento que estamos poniendo para
que no salga tanto el calor como
quisiéramos que saliera esto esto está
claro el efecto invernadero que es algo
que muchas veces se desconoce es
fantástico es lo que hace que esté este
mundo sea habitable que nuestro planeta
sea habitable el problema está en que si
no controlamos los gases los gases de
emisión que se llaman de efecto
invernadero de calentamiento lo que
vamos a tener es más
cristales y entonces esto se va a ir
calentando más y más y más hasta que
llegará un momento en que en vez de ser
habitable pues lo mismo en vez de tener
habitantes pues lo que tenemos aquí son
supervivientes porque esto se pone se
pone complicado
hacia dónde vamos hacia dónde vamos
bueno ha aumentado la temperatura un
poquito muy poquito
06 un grado probablemente ya estas
alturas un grado grado de temperatura
dice es muy poco estoy acostumbrado a
que el león en que entre la noche y el
día hay muchísima diferencia me van a
contar a mí lo que es un grado bueno
pues un grado vamos a meter lo vamos a
ponerlo desde otro punto de vista
voy a ponerle una calefacción subir de
20 a 21 grados supone aumentar
aproximadamente un 8 un 10 por ciento el
consumo de combustible
y hemos aumentado hemos dado a nuestra
atmósfera de momento mucha más energía y
sabemos dejo para que ella haga lo que
quieran y son cinco mil 300 billones de
toneladas lo que hemos metido en la
atmósfera más el agua de los océanos más
la tierra es decir hemos metido
muchísima energía
y ya llevamos un grado
nuestras expectativas es a ver si no
pasamos de un grado y medio el próximo
siglo porque las cosas se ponen
complicadas como les voy a explicar
ahora
y esperemos no llegar a 2
hay una serie de figuras que suelen voy
a dirigir a los de atrás que los pobres
les estoy dando la espalda y hay una
serie de diapositivas que ver antes de
este tipo que son los impactos que se
producen una serie de cosas más extremos
es decir más caídas de granizo más
lluvias más sequías
bueno pues con un grado verán que en un
grado que es lo que aparece ahí en gris
y en una escala que lo que mide es el
impacto desde lo más pequeño hasta lo
más grande en un grado que es lo que
estamos atravesando tenemos un cierto
impacto
cuando lleguemos a grado y medio que
probablemente no tardará muchos años el
impacto ya empieza a ser bastante serio
en muchos actividades de las que
nosotros hacemos y si llegamos a dos nos
tenemos que preparar
2 grados habremos metido una cantidad de
energía increíble dentro la luz
qué significa esto
en este momento sabemos que hay muchas
más situaciones más frecuentes de
calentamiento de sequías de huracanes
del deshielo etcétera etcétera fíjense
ustedes que una cosa muy simple antes
salía en televisión cuando venía una
catástrofe este tipo nunca habíamos
visto esto antes ahora ya sale y dice
esto es terrible porque cuando me estaba
reponiendo de la última vez que tuve una
riada me ha venido la segunda es decir
esto se está dando con más y más y más
frecuencia por tanto las cosas se están
complicando en unas regiones
evidentemente más que más que en otras
sí claro y como se para pues todos los
impactos que estamos teniendo sólo hay
una solución no pasar de grado y medio
fíjese que con grado y medio vamos a
tener problemas pero la solución es bien
clara una reducción tiene que producirse
entre el 70 y el 95 por ciento respecto
a lo que emitíamos hace unos años y
tiene que ser para el 2000
y esto va a ser difícil pero hay que
hacerlo y si no pues tendremos que ser
supervivientes de este de este planeta
esto del cambio climático volviendo a
los modelos pues todos sabemos que
efectivamente a unos les tocará más a
otro les tocará menos pero estamos
viviendo la lotería del que es la
lotería del pues lo que estamos
acostumbrados a ver cuando viene una
tormenta como están viendo ahora en él
en el vídeo viene esa tormenta viene
hacia nosotros nos va a pillar de lleno
nos va a pasar al lado pues eso es lo
que estamos jugando con la con la
lotería con la lotería del que
eso es el calentamiento global y les les
voy a enseñar para que se queden ustedes
con la imagen de que el calentamiento
global y el cambio climático es como una
piedra a nadie le da miedo la piedra
está aquí que es lo que estamos haciendo
la estamos levantando hacia arriba
y cuando venga estaremos nosotros abajo
eso es el cambio global y el
calentamiento climático tenemos que
cuidar la piedra muchas gracias
[Aplausos]